our subject for the day there's always but
there is always but is our subject for today
lord how are they increased that trouble me
many are they that rise up against me many they
be which say of my soul there is no help for
him in god but thou o lord at a shield for me
my glory and the lifter up of my head
i cried unto the lord with my voice
and he heard me out of his holy hill i laid me
down and slept i awake for the lord sustained me
i will not be afraid of ten thousands of people
that have set themselves against me round about
arise o lord save me o my god for thou has
smitten all my enemies upon the cheekbone
thou hast broken the teeth of the
ungodly salvation belongeth unto the lord
thy blessing is upon thy people i thank god
again for another day of life i frequently say
although it may be a little depressing that last
night all over pennsylvania where we are people
went to sleep and this morning they were found
dead it happens everywhere nursing homes hospitals
they're found on the streets on the battlefield
in private homes every night people go to bed
expecting to wake up in the morning and some
are found lifeless and it happened this morning
but we are alive and the question we may ask is
why did god preserve me surely he did not give us
another day to sin more he's given us another day
that we may draw closer to him and that we may do
that which is pleasing in his sight god is a god
of mercy god is a god of extended second chances
and third his mercy is exceedingly elastic
and sometimes we misinterpret that as divine
slackness but god isn't slack he's simply merciful
so he's given us one more day and i hope that
you will feel a burden to draw closer to your god
because he's given you life and god gives us life
in order that we might glorify him not ourselves
i'm grateful to god for this privilege of speaking
for him and i will do all that i can to represent
him by simply proclaiming thus saith the lord our
subject for the day there's always but there is
always but is our subject for today welcome to
all those connecting i'm particularly pleased
to welcome those of you who are not seventh-day
adventists wherever you are on god's green earth
thank you very much for your interest in truth
and for worshiping with us in this fashion we
thank god for modern technology surely knowledge
has increased i welcome the little children who
may be watching little boys little girls god can
speak to you jesus loves you and at one point in
his life jesus was your age so if the little boy
is watching and little girls thank you very much
for loving jesus and the father if there's anyone
suffering from the coronavirus i will pray and ask
a merciful god to deliver you from that affliction
and that you may use your health for his glory
our subject there's always but before i get into
it as always i ask you to preserve an atmosphere
of reverence wherever you are god is god 24 hours
a day seven days a week he isn't just holy on
sabbath god is holy consequently when we interact
with god we should do it with the consciousness
that we are in the presence of the holiest of
the holy favor number two pray for me while
i'm speaking all i ask is that you say to god
father o lord put your words in that man's
mouth jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 says then the
lord put forth his hand and touched my mouth the
reality is god is divine my mouth is earthy sinful
god takes his divine word and puts it in my human
earthy clay mouth and that's that's a privilege i
cannot measure and so you simply pray to god and
ask him to tell me what to say let me complete
the verse then the lord put forth his hand and
touch my mouth and the lord said unto me behold i
have put my words in thy mouth who is i the
universal authority on truth that is god
not the writers of the encyclopedia britannica
but god himself has promised to give me his words
favor number three think as you listen
concentrate isaiah 118 come now let
us reason together seth the lord there's an
example of god calling us to reason jeremiah 12
5 if thou has run with the foot men and they have
weary thee how cans then contend with the horses
you cannot keep up with a man how do you plan to
keep up with the horse god calls upon us think
what are you doing think reason together let's
pray father in heaven we thank you for life
you are the source of all life you are life
thank you so god so much for opening our eyes
immediately god we recommit our lives to you we
acknowledge your goodness half the day has passed
as we count time but if within that time we've
offended you we ask you today god to forgive us
you love to forgive exercise that love now
and forgive us have mercy upon me dear god
i am called upon and i am weak and it's my
duty to do a very very serious spiritual work
help me by granting me your spirit but an
angel to stand next to me father and fill me
with your spirit that my words may represent
the throne of grace and the throne of glory
bless those who listening father if anyone
listening has contracted the coronavirus
deliver that person from that thing father heal
that person their god simply because you love to
be merciful whether the person is a believer or
not because your word says he maketh his son to
rise on the evil and on the good and sendeth reign
on the just and on the unjust bless the children
watching father touch their little minds as you
touch the mind of john the baptist as you touch
the mind of jeremiah from the womb as you touch
the mind of the human jesus touch their minds and
bless our guests in a very special way bless the
leaders of countries god let them make decisions
that are consistent with this biblical principle
righteousness exalted the nation bless this church
bless the pastor the leadership thank you again
father for the privilege of speaking for you
now i commit this service to your glory and
your glory alone in jesus name i pray amen
there's always but let us go to
mark 11 we shall read from verse 23
i am reading from the king james version
of the bible mark 11 reading from verse 23.
mark is the shortest of the four gospels very
interesting gospel fast-paced gospel mark 11
reading from verse 23 for verily i say unto you
that whosoever shall sin to this mountain be thou
removed and be thou cast into the sea and shalt
not doubt in his heart but shall believe that
those things which he saved shall come to pass he
shall have whatsoever he saith jesus now people
use that and they add to it verse 24 therefore
what things so every desire when you pray
believe that you receive them you shall have them
and people have written me several times but i
prayed and i believed and nothing happened what's
our subject there's always but understand that
god is a god of conditions and this is watching
prayer and work god is a god of conditions yes but
and so many of us are disappointed when we pray
and we think we believe but there's no belief
that god accepts outside of thus said the lord
belief that moves heaven is belief that grows
out of thus saith the lord god does what he
does in a very disciplined and organized way
the bible says let all things be done decently and
in order that includes praying elohy frequently
talks about the science of prayer the science
of salvation which means there is a way to do it
when it comes to praying to god we must always
remember that answered prayers have conditions
now if you go back to verse 24 therefore what
things so every desire when you pray believe you
receive them and you shall have them and when
ye stand praying if you have ought against any
we are to forgive now here's a condition for
answered prayer that no one thinks about when they
harp on mark 11 24 i prayed i believed and nothing
happened for some reason they never read verse 25
if you forgive that your father also may forgive
your trespasses your sins forgiveness of sins a
willingness to forgive to make things right
is associated with the willingness of god
to answer prayer because god does not forgive
the person who consciously refuses to forgive
now reason with me here is god listening to
your prayer and he's watching you and jesus
is watching you he's your intercessor and the holy
spirit is watching you the angels are watching you
and you were praying i am praying father give
me a house. and god says but i can't forgive
him his sins but i'll give him a house i can't
forgive him sins but i'll give him whatever
there are conditions and that passage we use so
frequently to complain that god did not answer
our prayer it has a condition there are many
conditions to answer prayer and one condition is
if you have ought against any forgive that person
that your father also which is in heaven may
forgive you if there is a circumstance where god
cannot forgive then god cannot answer the prayers
there's always but let us go to
first john 5. we'll read verse 14
and 15 of john chapter 5.
i'll pray again father talk to me talk to me
and talk through me i pray in jesus name amen
you have first john 5 14 written by the
same person who wrote the gospel of john
and the person who wrote the book of revelation
and this is the confidence that we have in him
if we ask anything according to his will he
heareth us and if we know that he hear us
whatsoever we ask we know that we have the
petitions that we desire we desired of him now
here's one major condition for answered
prayer we must pray according to the will
of god and immediately i can hear someone
say but how do i know the will of god
let me give you the will of god in
condensed form in a when i was a little boy
we we we were given an essay to write we'd
be we will be asked to write a precede
of that essay which is just a condensed word a
summary fancy word is praising what is the summary
of the bible what is the precede what is the will
of god condemned and there's 66 books of the bible
covering 1500 years the ten commandments of god
are the condensed will of god to pray according
to god's will is to pray in the light of the
righteousness that god requires of us as expressed
in the commandments and lived in the life of
jesus christ this the will of god is expressed
in his law i don't mean the law of sacrifices i
mean the great law of ten commandments spoken by
christ himself father father on top of mount
sinai and repeated by moses in deuteronomy 5
and this is the confidence that we have in
him if we ask anything according to his will
he heareth us we encountered one condition in mark
11 25 when you stand praying if you have ought
against any forgive that your father also which is
in heaven may forgive your trespasses or your sins
this is a condition in other words holding grudges
blocks god's willingness to answer my prayer and
answer your prayer holding grudges let me pause on
this point and appeal to you there may be someone
listening to me who has not forgiven someone who
you should forgive you have not forgiven for years
the person heard you 25 years ago you go to
church you return your tithe you sing loudly
you're in the choir you're the head deaconess
but you will not forgive that person unless you
do that and you know you ought to forgive unless
you do that the bible says god cannot forgive you
and a refusal to forgive blocks god's gifts to
us because all the gifts of god are promised
on condition of obedience christ object
lessons page 145 paragraph one all his gifts
are promised on condition of obedience christ
object lessons page 145 paragraph one it is also
found in letters to young lovers page 83 paragraph
one all the gifts of god are on condition of
obedience to his word or to his will and so the
bible tells us if you'd like that mountain to move
when you pray make sure you have forgiven those
who've offended you and that you have apologized
to those whom you have offended clear that
rubbish clear that blockage out that the lord
may receive and answer prayer there is always but
and so if this is the confidence we have in him
i like the word confidence sometimes
we can't trust our own family members
can't trust your supervisor can't trust your
politicians can't trust your church leaders
you can always trust god this is the you see god
i usually demonstrate that but i can't do it here
here's a wall many years ago i worked
in a a home for encourageable boys
beyond correction they were taken out
of homes and placed in this place and
we would come in as workers on shifts
and monitor them and whatever else
we were playing a team building game an
exercise and this particular exercise
was scary the boys were lined up in two lines
and they had to interlock their hands like this
now someone would stand on a chair with his or
her back turned and you had to just fall back
believing those incoming boys will catch you
god is like that our trust in him you can just
fall back and god will catch you or here's a wall
you can just lean your full weight on that wall
it will not move because that's god this
this is the confidence that we have in him
that if we ask anything according to his will
with his conditions he heareth us there is
not a condition for god answering our prayers
let's go to proverbs 28 let's read verse 9. our
subject there's always but proverbs 28 verse 9.
we'll encounter a word in that
verse that's a little frightening
proverbs 28 written by solomon the son of
david the wisest man who ever lived the
man who made the silliest decisions ever
made but the wisest man who ever lived
he that turneth away his ear from hearing the law
even his prayer shall be what an abomination the
bible has abominations and it has sins now they're
all sins but an abomination is an intense sin
without offending anyone
let me give you an example
a man and a woman coming together for physical
relations who are not married that is sin in
the eyes of god and if not confessed
will result in the loss of the soul
but a man and a man coming together that is
also sin but that's a step further that is
abomination because it goes contrary to the
laws of nature the man and the woman outside
of marriage yes is sin but as still it is still
a natural act are you following what i'm saying
it is sin but a natural act it is sin but a man
and a man a woman and a woman a man and an animal
that is abomination
now keep this in mind listen to proverbs
28 9 he that turneth away his ear
not someone who's ignorant someone who says don't
tell me i don't want to know i couldn't care
less he or she who does that even that person's
prayer shall be an abomination in the eyes of god
and some of us in church we practice that as
i said earlier we know there's some things we
ought to do things we ought to make right sins to
forgive sins to apologize for and we absolutely
refuse but we go to god in prayer and our prayers
arise before god as a stench in his nostrils he
that turneth away his ear in second peter chapter
3 verse 5 the bible says for this they willingly
are ignorant of many years ago i was conducting an
evangelistic series in the city of detroit close
to where i live that's my home airport three weeks
we met every night this lady came the first week
and she came she was blessed then i did not see
her at the beginning of week number two so i
called her on her job and i said sister whomever
i didn't see you you know what she said to me
she said eldesquit i cannot keep coming. because
if i keep coming and sit under that preaching i
will have to make a decision so i am not coming
back now that's honestly you must respect
but that's a well-spoken form of self-destruction
i am not coming back because if i do
that word will cause me to make a decision
and i'm not ready for that based on where i
am in my life he that turneth away his ear
from hearing the law because often in the
bible the word law does not only mean the ten
commandments it means the revealed will of god
he that turneth away his ear you know you ought
to return a tithe and you do not this text does
not embrace those who are ignorant acts 17 verse
30 and the times of this ignorance god winked at
john 15 22 if i had not come and spoken unto them
they had not had sin we are talking about those
who deliberately do not want to know in the
eyes of god ignorance must have two qualities
quality number one i did not know quality number
two i had no way of knowing that is ignorance in
god's eyes this does not qualify for those in
second peter 3 5 for this they willingly are
ignorant of it does not cover the arrogant ones
in proverbs 28 9 he that turneth away his ear
from hearing the law the will of god
even his prayer shall be abomination
there are some people who tell you don't
tell me anything about the health message
i like my meat don't bother me with
the health message i like my meat
someone was talking to me some while ago
about an elder in some church and the elder
said someone had preached on health the health of
the church said no one will take my meat from me
well fine no one will take my meat from me now
biblically how you eat affects your character
it is not by accident that the very first victory
christ won was a victory of appetite what he would
consume of course he avoided food his victory
was over appetite the first adam fell on the
very same point this is not accidental it is not
accidental that daniel begins with a story on
diet this elder said no one will take my
meat from me he that turneth away his ear
from hearing the law even his prayer shall be an
abomination there is always but let me pray again
father continue to instruct me in what to say and
how to say it and when in jesus name i pray amen
we sabotage our own prayers it's not god god is a
god who sent christ surely is willing to give you
tuition now how do you compare christ if god will
give me christ why wouldn't he give me tuition
are you following me if christ if god will send
christ someone equal with himself the creator
and sustainer of heaven and earth why would he not
heal a cold or whatever but there's always a but
psalm 66 verse 18. go there
with me psalm 66 verse 18.
so by the way i recommended john i also
recommend psalms if you want to experience
the full range of human emotions read the psalms
read the psalms you see the humanity of those who
wrote the psalms most were written by david but
other people wrote some same with proverbs salman
wrote most of the people wrote psalm 66 verse 18
if i regard iniquity in my heart finish the verse
the lord will not hear me now what does
that mean if i not if i commit outwardly sin
if i regard iniquity let me give an
example there are some people who say
i have no problem with people who
smoke occasionally now i don't smoke
but i have no problem with those who do from
time to time on your birthday and thanksgiving
and valentine's day that's fine you
are regarding iniquity in your heart
i have no problem with uh those who go to the
games on sabbath and go fishing on sabbath
and go snorkeling on sabbath i have no
problem i don't do it but i have no problem
you don't have to do it to
be classified as part of it
i didn't say that clearly let me try to clarify
by using the bible in matthew 23 jesus condemns
the scribes and pharisees hypocrites you got you
build the tomb of the prophets of the s the saints
and garnish the chapucker of the prophets and
you say if we had been in the days our fathers
we would not have been partakers with them in
the blood of the prophets if they're saying we
didn't live back then we didn't do it jesus says
fill thee up then the measure of your fathers
in other words you are as guilty as
they are even though you did not do it
because their attitude towards old testament
prophets is your attitude towards me and i'm a
prophet this is a very serious concept you do not
have to physically commit the murder for god to
regard you as a murderer you simply have to have
the same mindset you regard murder in your heart
or i and so the bible says he if i regard
iniquity in my heart the lord will not hear me
so you can pray and fast and ask other people
to pray for you but there is a blockage
there is a blockage preventing the
transmission of god's goodness to you
and your prayer to god why
that sin there is always but
what have we seen so far
anything you ask god he'll give you the next word
is but you ask god anything either come unto me
you ask receive not because you ask a miss that
you may consume it upon your lust ask jesus said
ask and it shall be given you seek you shall
find knock and the door shall be opened unto you
but that has conditions and so we discovered in
mark 11 23 to 25 yes whatsoever things you desire
when ye pray believe that you receive them and ye
shall have them but verse 5 says there is a but
you must be willing to forgive those who have
offended you and apologize to those whom you
or i have offended we found out in first john
5 14 this is the confidence that we have in him
that if we ask anything according to his will
oh the the goodness of god the generosity of god
anything according to his will and so according
to his will puts a fence around the limits to
what we can ask god we can ask anything but what
he will give according to his will because there
are many requests that are not according to
his will lord give me that man's wife that no
no god will never do that father kill my enemy
no god will not do that father this father that
if we ask anything according to
his will what is the will of god
summarizing his law the word of god at large he
heareth us we discovered in proverbs 28 verse 9
he that turneth away his ear from hearing the
law even his prayer shall be an abomination
the bible says in second chronicles 20
20 believe his prophets socially prosper
believe his prophets socially prosper
you know the jews recognize christ as
a prophet but not the messiah the jews
their bible is mainly the old testament
it's part of our bible too christianity owes
a debt to judaism we can never never repay
elohim says every ray of light god has given
to the earth has come to the jewish nation
every ray of light the jews they have the
old testament recognize christ as a prophet
nice fellow but not the messiah but the old
testament which they use says believe his prophets
and jesus who was a prophet said i am the savior
are you following me no you're not my fault let
me try again jesus made it clear i am the savior
bible says believe his prophets they accept him as
a prophet but will not accept the fact he said i
am the savior i am god that's why he virtually
told the lady at the well in john chapter 4.
the bible says believe his prophet so shall he
prosper we have a prophet called ellen white
hey no matter where i go people are down on
that prophet they will not believe to disregard
disrespect try to minimize your influence the
bible says believe his prophets socially prosper
it is self-destructive to attack the gift god
has given to this church ellen white and what
i'm saying to you is that if i regard iniquity
in my heart and to dismiss god's prophets
is to act indicatively if i regard iniquity the
lord will not hear me my brothers and sisters
we looked at psalm 66 18 which is if i regard the
nickname in my heart the lord will only hear me
28 9 of proverbs if he that turneth away
his ear from hearing the law and the bible
talks of the law and the prophets the
lord the prophets always go together
and so i ask you on a very personal level do you
disregard the prophet god has given to this church
do you dismiss the counsel he
has sent us through her writings
god has given this church a gift not
given to any other church on the face
of the earth i may sound politically
incorrect but i'm biblically correct
no one hears the church like the church no
one dismisses the prophets like those to whom
the prophets are sent it wasn't the canaanites
that killed the prophets in the old testament
it was the jews it wasn't the canaanites
that put jeremiah in a pit it was god's
people it wasn't the romans that wanted
to kill christ pilar said three times
i find no fault in him the church said
we don't care we don't care we don't care
kill him and the many of us who say kill her
ellen white kill her there's always a but
forgive as a condition for answered prayer pray
according to god's will and to acquaint yourself
with god's will this must be your constant study
in order to acquaint because the spirit of god
will impress you what to say because romans 8 26
says we know not what we should pray for as we
ought the spirit makes intercession for us so we
need the spirit of god to guide our prayers let's
look at two other conditions for prayer let's
go to john 15. i'll pray father as i continue
to restrain my cardinal nature lord it doesn't
take long for the carnal nature to raise his head
push it back down that you alone may be glorified
in jesus name i pray amen john 15 we read verse
here is another verse that people use to complain
to god when he does not answer their prayers
john 15 reading verse 7 reading from the king
james version of the bible if he abide in me
and my words abide in you he shall ask
what he will and it shall be done unto you
and we use that to complain when god does not
answer our prayer but this is what the bible says
let's read john 15 1 to 10. there's
a particular word we're looking for
as we try to understand verse seven i am the
true vine and my father is the husband man every
branch in me that beareth not fruit he taketh
away and every branch that bear fruit he purges
it that it may bring forth more fruit now you're
clean through the word which i have spoken unto
you now let's identify this word verse four
what's the first word in verse four all right
i want you to give me a tally a number
of how many times you see the word abide
you'll also see the word continue it's the same
greek word menos abide continue same greek word
they mean the same thing so when you see continue
as that it means abide verse 4 john 15 abide in me
and i in you as the branch cannot bear fruit of
itself except it abide in the vine no more can ye
except he abide in me how many times did
we see abide in that verse four three times
i am the vine verse five here the branches he that
abideth in me and i in him the same bringing forth
much fruit for without me you can do nothing
for six make sure you're making up your tally
if a man abide not in me he is cast
forth that the branton is withered
and men gather them and cast
them into the fire and they burn
if he abide in me and my words abide in you he
shall ask what he will and it shall be done unto
you hearing is my father glorified that ye
bear much fruit so shall he be my disciples
as the father havely love me so have i loved you
continue ye in my love that word continue is abide
verse 9 if he keep my commandments he shall
abide in my love even as i have kept my father's
commandments and abide in his love now stop how
many times do we come across abide or continue
ten times then we are looking at a passage
of scripture where the central theme is what
come on you just told me abide
now give me another word for abide
continue now keeping those in mind give me
another word abide continue come on one more word
remain remain there's this teaching in the bible
once they've always said you have to remain
you have to continue now jesus says in verse
7 of john 15 having examined as we just did
if he abide in me and my words abide in you
under those conditions you shall ask what
you will and it shall be done unto you
you cannot have a hit-and-miss
relationship with god and i
expect him to answer every prayer you
utter on mata there must be an abiding
because when you abide you are behaving
like god why because god is always faithful
god is not up and down god is constant
in his love in his determination to save
in his stubborn affection for us he is constant
his love for us abides and he says now you be
like me you abide in me by abiding in my word and
having my word abide in you when that's the case
you will ask anything do you know why you'll
ask anything because the word abiding in you
will tell you what to ask for
because you cannot trust yourselves and
myself to know exactly what i should pray for
that's why we need the spirit i
told you the bible is very clear
in a very embarrassing way we know
not what we should pray for as we are
a family in a country overseas
had asked me for some guidance
on a college for their daughter in
the united states adventists and
we settled on a it's not a college it's not
a high school actually in canada called um
somewhere in british columbia forgotten fountain
view i've been there lovely place and so our
correspondence began the school was very very
helpful very willing to receive willing to
offer scholarship and people were willing to do
this and that and uh but it didn't work out and
a little girl was so despondent and the mother
said she asked me why is god doing this to me
shortly after that the pandemic broke and
schools were closed she would have been stuck
you understand what i'm trying
to say she would have been stuck
but her prayer was let me go to fountain view
let me go to the country in africa let me go on
that's no you know children young people how
they are it's an excitement i'm going to another
country let me go and god said no out of love but
she could not see why god kept closing doors until
the pandemic struck what am i trying to say we not
because we do not know the end from the beginning
we ask all sorts of things but god isaiah 46
verse 10 who knows the end from the beginning
he knows what's best and so through his
indwelling word he manages our requests
because if he granted some we would walk
straight into a swamp if he abide in me
and my words abide in your question now because
this is watch and pray how does the word of god
abide in our hearts just by memorizing it no
there's much more to it than that it must abide
as an active living principle that energizes and
directs the life that's why psalm 119 verse 105
thy word is what a lamp unto my feet and a light
unto my pair when we walk in the word of god
in the light of his word when that indwelling word
purifies us john 15 3 jesus told the disciples now
you clean through the word which i have spoken
unto you when this cleansing work works within us
our prayers arise like incense to god because that
spotless word which itself is divine instructs our
choices and instructs our prayers we cannot trust
ourselves to know what is best there is always but
mark 11 23 25 yes if you say that the mountain
move but have you forgiven those who've
offended you have you apologized to those whom
you've offended there is a but first john 5 14
if we ask anything according his will and his will
is that we forgive he heareth us proverbs 28 9 he
that turneth away his ear from hearing the law and
the lost sometimes mean all the revealed will of
god as we have in all the new testaments psalm
16 18 if i regard iniquity in my heart i don't
do it but i have no problem with those who do then
you're just as guilty just as guilty i don't drink
but it's fine if you drink i'm not a homosexual
but it's fine if you practice it i don't rob
banks but it's fine if you do then in the eyes of
god i am no different we looked at all these buts
then we came to john 15 7. if he abide in me and
my words we have to study god's word and obey
ella white writes in christ object lessons
page 100 paragraph one if studied and obeyed
they have to go together the word of god works
in the heart subduing every unholy attribute
not most every is it pornography
you can't stop going to those sites
the word of god will cleanse your mind of that is
it stingy you hate returning a dime for offering
the word of god will cleanse you that are you
always getting mad at the drop of a hat the
word of god will cleanse you of that that's why
the bible says in ephesians 5 26 husbands love
25 husbands love your wives even as christ
also love the church and gave himself for it
that he might sanctify and cleanse it
with the washing of water by the word
then we go now to another condition another but
let's go to first thessalonians chapter five
first thessalonians chapter five it's just three
words you know it verse 17 what does that say
come on tell me what does he say three
words and we're talking about prayer
pray it's without ceasing you don't have to
find it now let's pray without cease now let's
pause and think but let me pray father as i move
towards this latter part of this message continue
to instruct me lord in how i say it and what i say
and when in jesus name i truly pray amen listen
to three words pray without ceasing when naaman
went to elijah at the recommendation of a little
captive maid he was a leper needs to be cleansed
elisha did not even come to the door he just sent
the servant tell him go and dip in the river
jordan how many times seven times why not one
seven times did not change the chemical
constitution of the jordan river naaman
complained i have cleaner rivers in damascus why
am i dipping in this dirty river there are clean
rivers i can see the sand i can see the fish you
can't see anything in jordan it is so muddy and
polluted why am i dipping and why seven why not
just touch me no seven dip dip dip again dip again
dip again we apply that to the prayer line
why do people ask me frequently why do i
have to pray when god knows what i want
i know you probably never heard that i've
heard it all the time if god knows what why
do i have to pray because praying is part of
spiritual living it is part of your spiritual
life it is a spiritual principle it is essential
for spiritual growth and it demonstrates
your ongoing sense of dependence upon god
and so the bible says pray without
ceasing take out without ceasing
how else could you say that pray how
take out without ceasing now tell me
pray always tell me something else pray
continuously tell me something
else praying pray what
fervently and pray persistently
many prayers are not answered
because we stop praying too quickly
let's go to genesis 25.
genesis 25 our subject is always but
genesis 25
we read verses 40 not 40
sorry 20 and 21 of genesis 25.
and isaac was 40 years old when he took rebecca
to wife the daughter of bethuel the syrian of
pedanaram the sister 11 the syrian and isaac
entreated the lord for his wife because she
was barren and the lord was entreated of him
and rebecca his wife conceived now how old was
isaac when he began to pray that his wife would
become fertile how old was he 40. go to verse 26
read the last part of that verse
and isaac was three score years
when she bear them how much is three score how
old was isaac when he finally got a spray answered
so how many years did he pray that's my question
20. now what's first thessalonians 5 17 what does
it tell us pray now i'm not saying you must always
pray 20 years to get anything i'm not saying that
but i'm simply saying that one of
our spirit in our spiritual heritage
our ancestry of faith we have one of
our spiritual fathers he prayed 20 years
not because god was trying to develop the
skill to answer it was for his own development
and for reasons best known to god
abraham came into canaan when 75 years old genesis
12 verse 7. just around that time he got recalled
from god he had isaac when he was a hundred you
tell me how long did abraham pray 25 again let
me put your mind at ease we do not have to pray
25 years for the lord to remove a pimple or call
call or care whatever call um cure whatever we're
asking no but i'm trying to let you know that we
have a history in our spiritual background of our
fathers of faith praying and praying and praying
how many times did elijah pray before the rain
came back seven times now could he have did god
hear him the first time yes but for some reason
god wants us to enter to impertune to plead
let him see how fervent we are in our
request as my sister said pray fervently
i gave you this verse yesterday hebrews 5 7
speaking of christ who in the days of his flesh
when he had offered prayers and supplications with
strong crying and tears what is the supplication
you are pleading when we plead with god
we're not pleading to a stony-hearted tyrant
we're showing god how serious we are you see many
of us we have an up and down relationship with god
on sabbath we love him during the
week well we don't remember him
up and down he answers the prayer we're
happy he does not answer according to our
will then we're depressed he gives me
the husband i prayed for i'm happy he
did not give me i'm depressed we have this
relationship with like this god is constant
so god says to you when you pray to me show
me how serious you are show me your constancy
ask me i'm not sadistic but you demonstrate the
depth of your sincerity ask me pray talk to me
why else would god want us to pray and pray and
pray when things are going well people don't pray
when i say don't pray they talk they don't pray it
was last time you saw someone praying and crying
oh god i have everything i need i have all the
money and no no no no watch someone at a funeral
at someone's bedside in the hospital with tubes
coming out of his or her nose and they're praying
and they're crying someone leaves the hospital
or doctor's office with a diagnosis of cancer
of the brain and comes home and people are crying
and they're praying oh god aren't you a nice god
god loves when we come to him in prayer
sometimes that's the only time we spend
time with god a brief prayer and we're gone
god sometimes arranges circumstances that allow us
to come to him because god enjoys our fellowship
we must understand god enjoys human fellowship
more than humans enjoy divine fellowship
let me say differently god is more eager to hang
out with us than we are to hang out with him
and his eagerness to be with us is proven
beyond refutation by the fact that jesus christ
came as one of us
there's always but does god want to answer
your prayer yes does he have conditions
yes all his gifts are promised on condition of
obedience christ object lessons page 145 paragraph
one and it's biblical you read deuteronomy 28
1-13 if you obey all these conditions you will
be the head always and not the tail god will
preserve you're going out you're coming in your
enemies will come against you one way they'll flee
from you seven ways what's the condition obey me
forgive someone
let this word abide in you
ask me to give you hatred for sin so
you do not regard iniquity in your heart
whether in your own life or in the life
of someone else ask god to give you
a a a law loving heart if i regard
if if he that turneth away his ear
from hearing the lord give me a love
for your lord because the law is love
the lord's life i don't say the
lord gives life it preserves it
adam god god gave adam life but
obedience would have preserved it
great controversy page 467 paragraph
four the law reveals to man his sin
but provides no remedy while it promises
life to the obedient it declares that death
is the portion of the transgressor it
promises life to the obedient romans 7
verse 10 the commandment which was ordained in
life i found to be unto death because of sin
there's always a but let me close by reminding
you of what you already know god loves you and
loves to fellowship with you what is the name of
jesus given to him by the angel we all know jesus
matthew 1 21 but the same angel said in verse
23 behold a virgin shall be with child and shall
bring forth a son and they shall call his name
emmanuel which being interpreted is god with us
goodness always flows from heaven to earth
all god asks for is a little faithfulness
from earth to heaven my faithfulness cannot
compare in size to god's faithfulness to me
because god is god and so when you pray today
ask yourself is this someone i need to forgive
mark 11 25 ask yourself am i praying
according to god's will first john 5 14.
i turning away my ear from hearing the truth
proverbs 28 9 do i regard iniquity in my heart
psalm 66 18 does the word of god abide
in me to instruct me john 15 7 do i pray
without ceasing first thessalonians 5 17
now let's go back to mark 11 24 do i pray
in faith faith is not arrogance faith is
not re presumption faith is total trust
reliance and dependence upon thus saith the lord
i say faith is not presumption god parted the red
sea told the israelites to cross they crossed and
were safe he did not tell the egyptians to cross
they crossed and were destroyed the same red sea
same dry land for a while same direction perished
these israelites crossed by faith the egyptians
tried it by presumption and they're in a watery
grave faith is not presumption faith is simply
relying 100 on thus saith the lord there is
always a but may the lord touch you and me so
that in all our interactions with him we may
try with the help of his holy spirit to fulfill
the conditions christ was given without condition
but he saves on condition let me say that again
christ was given without condition he was sent
without condition he saves on condition may
the lord help us to be aware of the conditions
conditions are not satanic impositions they're
not acts of slavery there are divine methods
of developing us spiritually in training
our minds to think like god and to think of
god at all time let us consider that in all our
interactions with god in all our praying there's
always a but and that but is the condition
of obedience to thus set the lord let's pray
father in heaven thank you for your word it
challenges lord to the core our carnal nature
thank you for truth and the transforming effect it
has when we accept it if i said anything i should
not have said forgive me i pray i ask that
your spirit will take my meager human effort
and somehow improve it father and present
it anew to the hearts of those who listened
dear god help us to love praying just for the sake
of praying which is fellowship with you shutting
out the world and just abiding in your presence
in prayer and conversation with our father our god
not because we want anything father you're not
a supermarket help us to love praying just to
hang out with you bless those who heard the word
prepare our hearts and minds for the next
presentation in jesus name i pray amen
you